hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
we have our seasonal video of talking
about the new event and how to get the
stuff the fastest as always so we're
gonna be talking about that and I'm
gonna be explaining what is a bootable
what is not just in case you are very
confused there is a lot of things being
added to the new event that I want to
clear up for some people so as long as
like to me if you do enjoy subscribe for
new and let's get started with today's
video so the biggest question is what
can you and what can you knock it from
doing these lootable quests and stuff
like that so you cannot get the
illustrious outfit and you cannot get
the new emote the emote is on whose fire
it's like 10,000 steel and you can't get
the mask outfits or the illustrious
outfits because they are 20,000 steel
those are steel you have to specifically
buy those you cannot get those anywhere
else everything else the new effect the
guy let the gal lays ultimate I believe
was the name there's the new battle
outfit the new ornament the new weapons
all that stuff is available that you can
get throughout these games and in
specific for the weapons you have to
play the character that you want the
weapons for if you want to get something
like the new outfit or the new ornament
it doesn't matter the character cuz
they're just gonna drop randomly but for
the weapon you have to specifically use
that character so if you're a longtime
viewer of the channel you already know
where this is going but the number one
best way to do this is with arcade
arcade every single time has not failed
it drops the most amount of loop
possible in a very short amount of time
depending on how good you are at doing
this quest now this event is going to be
spanning two weeks so if you happen to
be watching this like a week later from
when this is uploaded this specific
quest that I'm showing on screen may not
actually be the quest that you're doing
this is the current first week of the
event so the second week quest will not
apply to this one there gonna be two
different things so just for this first
week you can look up this small little
guide that I came up with to talk about
this but for next week you're kind of on
your own it's probably not too difficult
because it's just arcade but I just
wanted to preface that because this I'm
making this like a day after the event
came out yeah but the first one is a
three on one with enemies that have low
health but high damage they're
essentially glass cannons I basically
just focused up on the BP a lot more
since I'm a bit uncomfortable fighting
him still I'm very uncomfortable
fighting any shield character I just
want to make sure that the black prior
was
first and then I handled the other two
and that was pretty much it the next
round is a simple 1v1 with black prior
but she has bleed so keep that in mind
the bleed is pretty damaging depending
on how many times you get hit by the
shield and like I said before with me
I'm uncomfortable with her so I get hit
a lot after that though we come to round
three and round three is a big [ __ ]
it's a scent a glide and a PK and you
have about two minutes to survive
I was actually fighting the two of them
and then I was fighting the PK as you'll
see on screen I didn't realize that the
thing said survive I thought this was
another three on one with no modifiers
so that kind of confused me for a bit
but the PK ends up actually coming out
at one minute unless you rush straight
up to her which you really shouldn't you
want to keep this as low as possible and
maybe it's the character but I chose
soon da employed for like three hours
and still really couldn't beat this
maybe I'm just trash and I could totally
see Knut characters of a really good
anti gank like JJ excelling here but
like I for some odd reason could not
complete this but it's not a big deal
though because I had heard some people
that play actually completed the quest
that the last round is I believe a 1v1
and you get one attempt at it so you
either win it or you lose it and it's
over I'm unsure if if you like if you
lose do you not get rewards if it's only
if you win I think the quest actually
kind of forces you to lose but you could
still actually win it but I think the
game is betting that you're gonna lose
I've like I said I didn't get to the
round cuz I'm [ __ ] garbage but yeah
just to let you know I'm assuming that
you could do these three rounds and they
kind of just throw the fourth round let
the guy kill you and then just reset and
do this again for some nice rewards even
when I fail I still got like two or
three rewards which is pretty impressive
so honestly if you really do want to do
that and you're really not that great at
the 3rd round like I am you could always
do that and you're still gonna be
getting some rewards it's still there
potential but it's not the best thing in
the world of course you of course do
want to complete the whole thing now for
you people that do not have arcade it's
alright I got you guys covered - the
best thing you want to be doing for that
as either playing Dominion or the new
game mode that came out the breach PvE
type mode the new game mode for some
reason though wouldn't really start so I
cannot provide extreme like down to the
[ __ ]
rame of what exactly you should be doing
for the fights and stuff and who to plan
out for but because I only got one game
out of the hour or two that I tried to
keep up for the game just throw it up on
screen yeah like I said I only got to
play one game I really wish I could have
played more but I do know that some of
the curse set enemies do pop out at
around round three I was noticing a lot
of trends on specific characters like
lob ringers coming in around on the
fourth wave Blackfriars on the fifth
wave and a few others in the beginning
and I also spawned in mid game so I
completely missed the very beginning of
the fight I was we're already on capture
point two so I have no clue what happens
beforehand oh yeah it was it was
actually a very fun game mode and it can
work because I got about 2 to 300 words
as well but then you also have to take
into consideration is could you get you
know could you play a Dominion game and
get the same amount of rewards in less
time because if you've got like a four
stack with this new game-mode go for it
I feel like if you got a fourth deck
you've you totally clutched this oh yeah
that's really gonna be it just a quick
recap if you have arcade go play arcade
if you don't have arcade try the new
game mode maybe play some Dominion just
kind of do your regular grinding arcade
is gonna be the best way obviously it's
just that playing the weekly quest is a
little bit of a [ __ ] to do but it can
still work if you want to grind it from
there or if not you can always wait till
next week where they might be even an
easier one who knows you guys always
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe for
new I'm sorry for the very stuff the
video today but hopefully it still gets
my point across them what game modes
you're supposed to be playing yeah like
I said before like subscribe with that
take care guys peace out
you